integration gehört zusammen ist eine
idee obwohl was ideen angeht ist
vielleicht jetzt nicht so viel neues
gekommen also da könnte man vielleicht
noch mehr erwarten dass eben bei anderen
kandidatur auch neue politische ideen
lanciert werden das war jetzt hier nicht
gegenstand man ist so mehr auf der
kontinuität linie auch mit merkel in
gewisser weise also das ist so dass
diese kontinuität ist last und und und
auch chance lasst insofern wenn alle
diejenigen die gegen merkel was haben
werden gegen dieses team auch wasser
haben aber die chance ist natürlich dass
man hier eine kontinuität verbirgt ja
trotzdem die frage wir haben gehört jens
spahn hat auch überlegt sich mit
friedrich merz zusammen zu tun also die
frage war wie wahllos ist dieses diese
teambildung jetzt oder wie gut passen
auch armin laschet und jens spahn
zusammenbringt jens spahn einen
konservativen ansatz der ami lasche
zählt wie lautet ihre beurteilung also
im prinzip ist in der tat wie sie
beobachten natürlich eine gewisse
differenz bei den beiden erkennbar
gewesen in der vergangenheit zu tun sich
jetzt zusammen um die breite der cdu
abzubilden
wenn das klappt also wenn die sich beide
tatsächlich weiterhin ergänzen können
wird da natürlich das spektrum
aufgemacht
laschet war er gegenüber konservativen
denkens reserviert umgekehrt spanier
aufgeschlossen wenn sie sich beide jetzt
zusammentun dann hat das natürlich ein
gewicht andererseits muss man sehen
natürlich kommt es auf die bevölkerungs
meinung zentral an wer hat die die
stärkere zugkraft lokomotiv funktion ist
das
doch merz oder vielleicht auch rücken-
oder ist diese teamlösung in sich als
großes gewicht was man hier einbringt
jedenfalls im westen der republik so
stark dass das zieht bei einem parteitag
trotzdem jetzt die frage wie stark ist
sind jens spahn und armin laschet jetzt
geworden welche vorteile bringt diese
team lösungen für sie also sie haben
einen sehr großen landesverband den
größten landesverband nrw hinter sich
wie sieht es um die hausmacht aus sie
ist sie auch sind sie da auch klar im
vorteil gegenüber den beiden anderen
kandidaten die hausmacht ist insofern
natürlich gegeben als der
ministerpräsident hier antritt und man
eben natürlich ungern als delegierter
wahrscheinlich in den rücken fallen will
insofern hat er da sicherlich ein
gewisses pre die kuriosität besteht ja
jetzt deutschlandweit gesehen dass wir
alles mit nordrhein-westfalen figuren zu
tun haben die untereinander rivalisieren
und da hat vielleicht lasse durchaus ein
gewisses pre und wir haben wir gehört
ostdeutschland spielt hier eine rolle
aber offensichtlich nur eine
beigeordneter so würde ich das
interpretieren was was gerade hier in
der letzten frage geäußert wurde
wie teamfähig wir haben das schon gehört
also es wurden auch team lösungen
gesucht mit den so in diesem moment
gehen wir rüber in die
bundespressekonferenz wo friedrich merz
das wort hat sehen wir uns auch alle das
wird prima herzlich willkommen zur
zweiten veranstaltung heute mit dem
titel zur kandidatur für den cdu vorsitz
und dazu sitzt neben mir friedrich merz
frühere unions-fraktionschef der jetzt
das wort hat peter merz yahoo schon
meine damen und herren zunächst einmal
herzlichen dank dass sie in so großer
zahl erneut zu einer
bundespressekonferenz gekommen sind
wir leben in nicht nur spannenden
sondern auch aufgewühlten zeiten das
land ist polarisiert und wir erleben
anschläge
die täter attentate aus der
rechtsradikalen szene die uns alle tief
bewegen und auch politisch natürlich
beschäftigen
mir fällt es ein bisschen schwer jetzt
einfach so zur tagesordnung der
politischen partei parteien und auch der
cdu über zu gehen ich will trotzdem
sagen die cdu ist eine partei die gerade
in solchen zeiten ein stabilitätsanker
in deutschland sein muss und wir haben
leider zum zweiten mal innerhalb von 15
monaten eine neuwahl des oder der
parteivorsitzenden anstehen am 25 april
hier in berlin wird ein sonderparteitag
der cdu stattfinden mit der neuwahl des
oder der parteivorsitzenden
ich habe mich nach reiflicher überlegung
entschlossen bei diesem bundesparteitag
erneut für das amt des
parteivorsitzenden zu kandidieren und
ich will das auch begründen warum ich
mich dazu entschlossen habe meine damen
und herren ich habe am 17 dezember 2018
in hamburg auf dem bundesparteitag 48
prozent der stimmen bekommen
das war ein für mich gutes ergebnis nach
so kurzer zeit zurück in der politik
ich habe es zum anlass genommen der
partei auch anzubieten weiter behilflich
zu sein und sie weiter zu unterstützen
das hab ich insbesondere gegenüber der
parteivorsitzenden auch eingelöst wir
haben uns intensiv in den letzten 15
monaten immer wieder über verschiedene
themen unterhalten und kombination ist
leider nicht erfolgreich gewesen und
insofern stehen wir jetzt noch einmal
vor einer solchen wichtigen
entscheidungen vor einer
personalentscheidung aber diese
entscheidung ist auch eine
richtungsentscheidung für die cdu und
deswegen will ich kurz vier themen
ansprechen die aus meiner sicht wichtig
sind jetzt für die zukunft der cdu und
dann anschließend noch ein wort auch zur
aufstellung der partei sagen zunächst
einmal zu den vier themen das erste
thema es ist nicht ein bruch mit der
vergangenheit sondern ist ein aufbruch
unter einer neuerung für die zukunft die
cdu muss jetzt den blick
nach vorn richten auch wenn die
wahlperiode noch bis in den herbst 2021
dauern wird aber sie muss die zeit
danach in den blick nehmen und sie muss
ein paar themen setzen insbesondere für
die zukunft der jungen generation in
deutschland
wir müssen mehr tun für ausbildung und
bildung ich bin immer ein großer freund
der beruflichen bildung gewesen ich
halte dieses thema führen nach wie vor
sehr sehr wichtig und ich glaube dass
wir da mehr tun können
wir müssen das thema
chancengerechtigkeit für die junge
generation in den blick nehmen
insbesondere für die perspektive junger
frauen und ich glaube ich weiß worüber
ich da spreche ich habe selbst zwei
töchter die genau in dieser lebensphase
jetzt sind wo sie mit solchen fragen
konfrontiert sind wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass größere teile der
bevölkerung auch am wohlstand unseres
landes teilnehmen und wir müssen auch
darauf hinwirken dass es eine
ausreichende altersversorgung gibt die
ganze diskussion die hier in berlin
zurzeit über die grundrente stattfindet
zeigt dass hier ein ganz strukturelles
defizit haben in der altersversorgung
unserer bevölkerung das alles steht für
mich unter der überschrift eines neuen
generationenvertrages für deutschland
und ich will das hier ausdrücklich und
klar sagen ich halte entscheidungen der
großen koalition der letzten jahre
jeweils im einzelfall für begründbar
in der summe sind sie eine belastung für
die junge generation es werden lasten in
die zukunft verschoben auf die schultern
der jüngeren und da muss die cdu wieder
eine partei der jungen generation sein
wir müssen zweitens das vertrauen in den
rechtsstaat der bundesrepublik
deutschland zurück gewinnen
der innere frieden in unserem land ist
bedroht wir sehen an verschiedenen
stellen ich habe ein thema eben schon
angesprochen was in diesem lande los ist
und auch das will ich sagen wir haben in
diesem lande über viele jahre das
problem des rechtsradikalismus massiv
unterschätzt und das muss sich ändern
das ändert sich gerade
aber wir müssen gleichzeitig auch
rechtsfreie räume schließen es gibt zu
viele stadtteile brennpunkte in diesem
land in denen nach wie vor der
rechtsstaat herausgefordert wird außer
kraft gesetzt wird
und das muss sich ändern die partei muss
wieder eine partei ohne wenn und aber
des rechtsstaats bundesrepublik
deutschland sein
dazu gehört auch dass sie die nach wie
vor stattfindende illegale einwanderung
in die bundesrepublik deutschland besser
unter kontrolle bekommen und wir müssen
als ultima ratio sowie die partei das im
letzten jahr auch beschlossen hat in der
lage sein wenn nichts anderes mehr hilft
auch unsere außengrenzen ausreichend zu
schützen die territoriale integrität der
bundesrepublik deutschland muss
letztendlich auch durch den schutz der
aussengrenzen gewährt werden wenn die
europäischen außengrenzen den
hinreichenden schutz nicht bieten
wir müssen drittens das land fit machen
für das einundzwanzigste jahrhundert
und wenn wir uns die gegenwärtige lage
anschauen dann müssen wir an
verschiedenen stellen feststellen dass
wir nicht wirklich gut vorbereitet sind
für die herausforderung des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts ich nenne
nur einige stichworte dass eine
stichwort ist die digitalisierung wir
sind hier viel zu weit zurück die
abhängigkeit von ausländischen
ausrüstern nicht nur chinesischen auch
amerikanischen ausrüstern ist ein
problem die ganze diskussion über huawei
ist im grunde genommen nur eine
stellvertreter diskussion dafür dass wir
hier einfach die autonomie in der
ausrüstung der digital industrie in
europa verloren haben wir hatten sie
wahrscheinlich nie wir müssen sie
gewinnen wir müssen mehr dafür tun dass
dies gelingt die energiepolitik in der
bundesrepublik deutschland ist ebenfalls
nicht zukunftsfähig so wie wir zurzeit
energiepolitik hier sehen in deutschland
reicht das nicht aus
auch dazu gebe ich nur ein kurzes
beispiel wenn wir es ernst meinen mit
der transformation der deutschen
wirtschaft in die co2 neutralität dann
werden wir einen exponentiell steigenden
strombedarf haben in deutschland der ist
durch wind und sonne alleine nicht zu
decken hier brauche es mehr und bessere
energiepolitik das dritte in diesem
zusammenhang fit machen für das
einundzwanzigste jahrhundert wir
brauchen moderne technologien ja da ist
einiges geschehen aber die einseitige
festlegung etwa der mobilität auf
elektromobilität reicht nicht aus andere
länder sind viel viel weiter wir
brauchen hier einen mix auch an
verschiedenen industrien
wir brauchen auch anreize für junge
unternehmen viel viel stärker auch in
deutschland zu bleiben wenn sie etwas
entwickelt haben wir sehen zu viele
unternehmen die deutschland
lassen weil sie etwa in amerika aber
auch in anderen teilen der welt bessere
zukunftschancen sehen als in deutschland
das alles geht viertens nach meiner
festen überzeugung nur dann wenn wir
mehr europa und nicht weniger europa
wagen
viele von diesen themen gehen eben nicht
im nationalen alleingang sie gehen nur
zusammen mit der europäischen union
ich stehe wie viele andere auch in der
cdu dafür dass die cdu die europapartei
in deutschland bleibt viele
entscheidungen der letzten jahre sind
nicht im konsens mit der europäischen
union getroffen worden manche sogar im
ausdrücklichen und offenen dissens ich
spreche noch einmal das thema
energiepolitik entspreche noch einmal
das thema einwanderungspolitik an das
geht nicht im nationalen alleingang
dafür brauchen wir europäische partner
und deswegen hätte ich es mir in diesem
zusammenhang auch gewünscht dass auf die
mehrfachen vorstöße des französischen
staatspräsidenten emanuel makro bessere
antworten aus deutschland gekommen wären
als sie gegenwärtig kommen
last but not least wenn wir es ernst
meinen mit außen- und sicherheitspolitik
und auch der robustheit unserer
verteidigung dann geht das ebenfalls
nicht im nationalen alleingang wir
brauchen die auch eine sehr viel
stärkere ausrichtung in der europäischen
außen- und sicherheitspolitik noch
einmal die cdu muss wieder die führende
europapartei der bundesrepublik
deutschland werden damit dies alles
gelingt wir haben seit heute einen
offenen wettbewerb in der cdu ich
begrüße das ausdrücklich dass das so ist
darüber freue ich mich denn das ist
demokratie das ist auch innerparteiliche
demokratie
das kann der partei nutzen das hat uns
2018 schon genutzt ich gehe davon aus
dass das auch 2020 so sein wird
es gibt allerdings auch sehr
unterschiedliche akzente wir sind alle
in einer partei wir wollen dass diese
partei wieder erfolgreich wird aber wir
haben sehr unterschiedliche auffassungen
dazu wie das geht und vielleicht darf
ich das so sagen ohne meinem freund eine
national zu treten aber wir haben ab
heute die alternative zwischen
kontinuität und aufbruch und erneuerung
ich stehe für aufbruch und erneuerung
der cdu bei den gegenwärtigen
wahlergebnissen die wir haben im bund
bei umfragen die
wobei 22 prozent liegen wenn man die csu
herausrechnet ergebnisse wie das am
vergangenen sonntag in hamburg sind nun
wirklich der letzte weckruf an die
volkspartei cdu
wir müssen besser werden wir müssen
zukunftsfähig werden wir müssen wirklich
aufbrechen in eine neue zeit und da geht
es nicht einfach so weiter wie bisher
und deswegen stehe ich so wie auch 2018
schon einmal dafür dass sich diese
partei wirklich grundlegend erneuert die
inneren strukturen der partei auch
angepackt werden
zukunftsfähig gemacht werden wir müssen
die modernste digitale partei werden der
bundesrepublik deutschland wir müssen
organisatorisch schnell aufholen damit
wir das schaffen was wir schaffen wollen
nämlich die bundestagswahl 2021 zu
gewinnen so und dafür stehe ich und
dafür werde ich auf dem bundesparteitag
am 25
in berlin kämpfen und ich sag das meinen
mitbewerbern nicht nur hier sondern auch
dient das auch vorher gesagt es gibt ein
datum das ist wichtiger als der
fünfundzwanzigste viertel das ist der 26
viertel
wir müssen am tag danach eine
aufstellung in der cdu haben die dieses
wirklich verkörpert zukunftsfähig zu
sein nach vorn zu schauen
den blick nach vorne zu richten in
dieses einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert und
in anspruch damit zu verbinden die
moderne volkspartei im dritten jahrzehnt
des 21 jahrhunderts zu sein
dafür stehe ich das werde ich als
angebote an die delegierten des
bundesparteitages abgeben und dafür
werde ich auch um die mehrheiten kämpfen
herzlichen dank danke so weit was sich
am anfang versäumt habe und gerne
nachholen möchte ist auch herrn täter zu
begrüßen dann nebenher merck setzt den l
pressesprecher von herrn merz der
gegebenenfalls der hier vorne sitzt weil
er geht ebenfalls auch für fragen zur
verfügung stehen
dann kommen wir zu ihren fragen ich habe
schon einige auf der liste und erinnere
auch hier nochmal an die fairness regel
bitte maximal zwei pro person
damit möglichst alle dran kommen und
frau vaters in der mitte hinten hat die
erste frage herr merz vor ihnen haben
sich die beiden an haben sich zwei
andere kandidaten vorgestellt die sehr
stark abgehoben haben
auf das thema teamlösung dass die cdu
auch eine teamlösung brauche und keine
spaltung weiter vertragen
warum haben sie sich nicht für eine
teamlösung bereit gefunden und zweite
frage was machen sie wenn dieses mal
wenn sie verlieren sollten
wie lassen sie sich dann einbinden in
die cdu wird das weiter so sein so ein
bisschen vom rande oder werden sie dann
bereits seien in irgendeiner funktion zu
gehen innerhalb der partei ja verfahren
ist wir haben in der tat lange über das
thema team gesprochen und ich habe immer
gesagt ich habe mein ganzes leben sowohl
beruflich als auch politisch immer in
teams gearbeitet und nie alleine
insofern war für mich völlig klar dass
ich auch dieses mal bereit bin in ein
team einzutreten nur ein team muss
geführt werden und ein team braucht
einen teamführer so und um diese frage
haben wir intensiv gesprochen wie das
auch hinzufügen
ich glaube armin laschet hat das hier
eben auch gesagt wir haben in den
letzten tagen eigentlich in den letzten
wochen sehr sehr ernsthafte sehr offene
sehr vertrauensvolle gespräche
miteinander geführt wir haben den ernst
der lage verstanden und es geht in der
tat nicht um die frage wer wird jetzt
von umziehe was sondern es geht um die
frage in welche richtung entwickelt sich
die partei in den nächsten jahren weiter
und an dieser stelle gibt es nicht nur
eine eine meinungsverschiedenheit in der
sache sondern wir verkörpern auch zwei
unterschiedliche richtungen so und da
sind wir beide der meinung dass die
delegierten auf dem bundesparteitag das
entscheiden müssen und dass wir das
nicht untereinander ausmachen können
sondern das ist eine frage die muss die
ganze partei dann entscheiden
ich habe armin laschet zugesagt ich
denke dass ich das sagen darf ohne die
vertraulichkeit der gespräche hierzu
verletzten dass ich für den fall dass
ich nicht gewählt werden sollte bereit
bin für den stellvertreter zu
kandidieren der dann ja frei würde mit
seiner wahl
aber diese frage hat sich mit dem
heutigen tag auch erledigt
und damit ist dann auch klar ich spiele
hier auf sieg und nicht auf platz
die nächste frage hat der kollege in der
mitte ich hoffe ich treffe das richtige
mikro sie sind gemeint genau der kollege
vom und ägyptischen medium sie schauen
mich an genau das ist das journal ist
helmes wie sehen sie die bundeswehr aus
also bei ihnen also es ist liegt auf der
hand dass die bundeswehr ist ein mode
hat marode ausrüstung grunde auch
personalmangel 20.000 aufziehen und
unter 18 sind unbesetzt werden sie die
wohnwert kapazität auf ausbauen oder
alles läuft wie es jetzt ist
ich habe der neuen bundes
verteidigungsministerin eine gekommen
karrenbauer in vielfältiger weise auch
schon rat gegeben ihr hilfestellung
angeboten im hinblick auf das amt das
sie als verteidigungsministerin ausübt
ich finde dass dieses ausgesprochen gut
macht und hier sind korrekturen dringend
notwendig gewesen
das ist ein langer weg die bundeswehr
ist nicht in dem zustand in dem sie sein
müsste um die aufgaben zu bewältigen die
ihr politisch gegeben werden und
insofern gibt es großen nachholbedarf
dies zu tun also die die deutsche marine
ist zum beispiel hat seit 2003 kein
student mehr also es gab hier zu stören
und sie sind schon jetzt ausgeschieden
nur gibt es freikarten wie sachsen oder
so also nichts starkes deutschland
irgendwie also ich schlage vor dass wir
unsere zustand der deutschen marine mal
gelegenheit in einer gesonderten
bundespressekonferenz noch einmal
ausführlicher unterhalten am sonntag
dazu kommen wir dann zu gegebener stunde
zurück das ist eben jetzt klar er die
nächste frage hat von uns
die gründe für das scheitern von frau
kramp karrenbauer und sind sie für eine
umbildung des kabinetts wenn sie
parteichef werden also das ist
sicherlich eine vielzahl hat eine
vielzahl von gründen sie selber hat das
ja in ihrer pressekonferenz am
vorletzten montag auch so gesagt ich
teile das was sie da gesagt hat und zu
den gründen des scheiterns ich bedauere
das wirklich sehr weil wir auch sehr eng
und freundschaftlich in den letzten
anderthalb jahren miteinander gesprochen
und gearbeitet haben
das muss sich ändern das muss anders
werden und der zukünftige
parteivorsitzende braucht auch innerhalb
der partei den notwendigen rückhalt und
auch die notwendige autorität um zum
beispiel solche dinge wie in thüringen
gar nicht erst entstehen zu lassen
das hätte in thüringen nicht passieren
dürfen und zwar vom ersten tag an nicht
man hätte in thüringen vom ersten tag an
eine ja einen plan a einen plan b haben
müssen wie gehen wir vor wenn dieses
oder jenes ergebnis eintritt das ist
nicht möglich gewesen das muss beim
nächsten mal besser werden die frage
einer regierungsumbildung stellt sich
zum gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt nicht
der bayerische partei vorsitzende der
csu hat das angesprochen
ich gehe davon aus dass das irgendwann
dann vielleicht stattfindet aber nach
meiner einschätzung wird das erst nach
dem bundesparteitag der cdu sein und
dann werden die beiden
parteivorsitzenden mit der
bundeskanzlerin darüber zu sprechen
[Musik]
gewesen was hätten sie da von anfang an
klargemacht naja für den plan a dass es
zu einer mehrheit nicht reicht
hätte man im plan b sagen müssen gut
wenn es denn für regierungsfähige
mehrheiten mit den politischen parteien
der mitte nicht reicht dann wäre zum
beispiel eine enthaltung im dritten
wahlgang eine option gewesen die man
hätte nehmen können und dann wäre eine
regierung gebildet worden eine
minderheitsregierung ohne dass man sich
die hände schmutzig gemacht hätte etwa
in der weise wie das dann durch die wahl
mit kemmerich
der fall gewesen ist ich hätte mir da
einfach mehr abstimmung auch mehr
führung erwartet auch durch die bundes
partei
herr blank hat die nächste frage in der
mitte märz bringt sie an als
kanzlerkandidat und wann sollte die
frage geklärt werden der
kanzlerkandidatur zum parteitag im
dezember oder anfang nächsten jahres für
die csu das will und könnten sie sagen
wie ihr team aussieht also werden sie
mit einem team antreten gibt es da schon
eine frau die sie im auge haben was wir
also wir wählen auf dem parteitag am 25
den parteivorsitzenden der cdu neu und
wenn einer der stellvertreter posten
frei wird einen der stellvertreter alle
anderen wahlen finden dann im dezember
statt
auf dem regulären parteitag dritter bis
fünfter zwölfter in stuttgart im falle
meiner wahl werde ich der partei in
jedem fall eine frau als
generalsekretärin vorschlagen und dann
auch in einer aufstellung in diesem
parteitag gehen mit vorschlägen wie wir
wirklich eine optimale aufstellung der
gesamten bundesparteitag auch der spitze
des präsidiums so vornehmen können dass
daraus dann die mannschaft für die
nächsten zwei jahre wird wir haben
bereits einige neue gesichter in der
führung der partei aber ich denke das
ist ein dauerhafter prozess und der wird
auch in stuttgart noch nicht zu ende
sein
ja die kanzlerkandidatur wird in
einvernehmen zwischen cdu und csu zu
einem späteren zeitpunkt entschieden und
deswegen halte ich sehr viel davon was
markus söder gesagt hat eins nach dem
anderen wir wählen jetzt den
parteivorsitzenden der cdu
und dann werden sich beide
parteivorsitzende miteinander
verständigen wie die verfahren sind und
der übliche weg ist dass die beiden
parteipräsidium dann zusammen treten und
sich über diese frage verständigen und
das wäre auch meine lösung
mit der nächsten frage gehen wir auf die
von uns gesehen rechte seite zu dem
kollegen dessen name ich mir vorhin
wieder nicht gemerkt habe genau
ja er will survive n-tv und rtl
[Musik]
im märz hatten sie eigentlich ihre
kandidatur vorab angekündigt und
besprochen mit der bundeskanzlerin
werden sie ja sollten sie gewählt werden
mit angela merkel zusammen arbeiten
müssen und wann haben sie eigentlich das
letzte mal mit angela merkel gesprochen
und noch zu einer anderen aussage sie
meinten man hat hier die wahl zwischen
kontinuität oder aufbruch erleichtert
tritt er nicht alleine tritt zusammen
mit herrn sparen
halten sie dieses duo für glaubwürdig
dass also beispielsweise dieser art
spahn das thema aufbruch auch glaubhaft
vertritt also mir steht es nicht zu die
beiden jetzt persönlich zu bewerten
aber ich sag mal im richtigen leben
würde man vielleicht von einer
kartellbildung zur schwächung des
wettbewerbs sprechen mich aber das ist
völlig in ordnung und legitim dass die
beiden das machen aber damit ist auch
klar dass wir wirklich jetzt
unterschiedliche überzeugungen haben
davon wie es weitergehen soll und ich
sage das wirklich ohne jede kritik das
ist vollkommen in ordnung die cdu muss
eine solche richtungsentscheidung
treffen die kann ich und will ich ja
auch nicht ersparen müssen
ich bekomme so viel zustimmung in der
öffentlichkeit ich schaue ja auch auf
meine umfragen also dass das ist jetzt
nichts was mich jeden tag beschäftigt
aber ich schaue ja auch hin wie die
zustimmung in der bevölkerung ist und
ich habe denen ganz sicheren eindruck
dass die mehrheit der partei aber auch
die mehrheit der bevölkerung von der cdu
erwartet dass sie jetzt in bestimmten
fragen eben auch eine neue richtung
einschlägt und dass sie da bestimmte
dinge eben nicht einfach nur fortsetzt
ich habe mit der bundeskanzlerin am
rande des letzten bundesparteitag in
leipzig kurz gesprochen
ansonsten gilt das was sie selber gesagt
hat sie hält sich aus dem prozess der
neuen parteispitze und ihre erfindung
heraus und das halte ich auch für
richtig und angemessen
die nächste frage hat herr inkl
kurz danach mag ihnen wird hier
unterstellt dass sie aber die größten
probleme im fall einer wahl mit der
zusammenarbeit mit der bundeskanzlerin
hätten deswegen hätte ich ganz gerne
gewusst ob sich die aussehen und würden
sie dafür plädieren dass die kanzlerin
damit sie nicht dieselben probleme
hätten wie annegret kramp karrenbauer zu
einem früheren zeitpunkt als september
20 21 abtritt die bundeskanzlerin ist
gewählt bis zum ende der wahlperiode des
deutschen bundestages und das gilt für
alle
und im falle meiner wahl ist
selbstverständlich so wie ich das auch
2018 in hamburg gesagt habe wir haben
dann beide eine staatspolitische
verantwortung die über unsere eigenen
personen hinausreicht und ich gehe davon
aus dass wir einen vernünftigen weg
finden werden uns da auch zu
verständigen ich würde allerdings im
falle meiner wahl beanspruchen dass
sachverhalte wie sie in thüringen
ausschließlich von der partei
beantwortet werden und ihrem
vorsitzenden und nicht aus dem
bundeskanzleramt heraus das sind sachen
die dann in der partei geklärt werden
müssen und die mustern auch ein
parteivorsitzender alleine in eigener
verantwortung und zuständigkeit klären
und insofern glaube ich wird das dann
etwas deutlicher und klarer auch in der
aufgabenverteilung der schule hat die
nächste frage als wären sie den aufbruch
und die erneuerung so stark betonen ist
dass indirekt auf jeden fall doch immer
eine abgrenzung mit der kanzlerin und
hat der bayerische csu chef gesagt
abgrenzung von der kanzlerin bruch mit
der kanzlerin allein reiche ihm nicht
haben sie jetzt ein vorher noch ein
paket draufzulegen um sozusagen die
zukunftsfähigkeit noch verstärkt zu
unterstreichen und das andere ist auch
herr laschet hat gesagt dass die
entscheidung über den vorsitz eine
vorentscheidung über die
kanzlerkandidatur ist hat also söder nur
noch ein vetorecht wenn die cdu gewählt
hat also zunächst einmal ist auch meine
feste überzeugung und ich habe das immer
wieder auch in den letzten wochen zum
ausdruck gebracht das sind 15 dann
vielleicht 16 jahre für deutschland die
teil unserer geschichte werden
die war nicht einfach
ungeschehen machen können selbst wenn
wir es wollten und ich will es
ausdrücklich nicht das ist teil unserer
geschichte und die bundesrepublik
deutschland steht heute ausgesprochen
gut da bei allen problemen die wir haben
über die wir reden müssen aber wir
können im grunde genommen doch sagen das
war ein gute 15 jahre für deutschland 16
jahre wenn es die dann werden und das
ist auch in ordnung so aber das ist dann
ein abschnitt der sich abschließt und
wir müssen den blick nach vorne richten
und nicht nur einfach eine 15-jährige 16
jährige geschichte fortsetzen linear
sondern wir müssen wirklich einige
korrekturen auch vornehmen das erwarten
die wählerinnen und wähler von uns und
das erwarten auch unsere mitglieder und
im übrigen wir hätten nicht so viele
wähler verloren und so viele mitglieder
verloren
wenn das jetzt alles prima wäre und nur
noch fortgesetzt werden ich darf daran
erinnern wir haben jenseits der leider
sehr hohen sterbequote in der
mitgliedschaft der cdu dadurch dass wir
eine überalterte mitgliedschaft haben
wir haben mindestens 100000
wahrscheinlich 150 tausend mitglieder
verloren im westen lebensalter die sich
abgewendet haben von der cdu wird eine
meiner ersten aufgaben sein dafür zu
sorgen dass diese ehemaligen mitglieder
zur cdu zurück finden
wir müssen die wieder zurückholen weil
die enttäuscht sind über das was in den
letzten jahren aus ihrer sicht nicht gut
genug war so und das sind fragen die
muss jeder neue parteivorsitzende für
sich beantworten ich beantworte sie
genauso wie es ihn heute sage und markus
söder hat recht es ist kein bruch
sondern es ist ein aufbruch in eine neue
zeit und die frage wie wir uns über die
frage ist kanzler kandidaten
verständigen ist völlig klar und
eindeutig die beiden parteivorsitzenden
die verantwortung sich darüber zu
verständigen ihren parteipräsidenten
einen vorschlag zu machen und da sind
beide gleichberechtigt cdu und csu ich
habe großen respekt vor der leistung der
csu aber sie ist eben auch nur ein teil
der union der größere teil ist der cdu
und darüber müssen wir dann vernünftig
miteinander reden und markus söder und
ich wir kennen uns lange genug um zu
wissen dass wir das auch wirklich können
für die nächste frage gehen wir ein paar
reihen weiter nach hinten zu herrn römer
ich sehe das mikro leider nicht von hier
ist das richtige das richtige ja herr
merz ich würde gerne nochmal auf das
scheitern von annegret kramp karrenbauer
zurückkommen sie fand es in der letzten
woche notwendig zu erwähnen dass die
verlierer des jetzigen führungsstreit
mit sicherheit geschlossenheit zeigen
würden nach der wahl sich an das
ergebnis halten ist frau kramp
karrenbauer auch daran gescheitert dass
sie wenigstens aber ihre anhänger sich
mit dem ergebnis 2018 eigentlich nie
abfinden konnte und der innere
führungsstreit weiter schwelte die frage
die sich daran anschließt wie wollen sie
verhindern dass das im nächsten fall
wieder so ist und wenn sich die lage in
diesem jahr anders darstellt als 2018
dann ist das sicher richtig die frage
die sich daran anschließt haben sie sich
verändert
also die erste frage beantworte ich mit
einem ganz glasklaren nein im gegenteil
ich habe auf dem bundesparteitag in
hamburg unter dem großen beifall der
delegierten gesagt und mich daran
gehalten was ich dort gesagt habe dass
ich sie in jeder weise unterstützen in
ihrer arbeit die sie von da an zu
leisten hatte das weiß sie das hat sie
auch glaube ich einige male öffentlich
gesagt wir haben ein ausgesprochen gutes
persönliches verhältnis zu einander
völlig ungestört bis zum heutigen tag
und sie konnte sich auf meine loyalität
und meine zustimmung zu ihrer arbeit
immer stützen
es gibt nicht eine einzige wortmeldung
von mir weder öffentlich noch nicht
öffentlich mit realer kritik an hier
sachlich das eine oder andere diskutiert
ich bin da immer vollständig loyal
ich habe ein ganz altmodisches
verständnis von führung
wenn entscheidungen getroffen sind haben
sich alle anderen daran zu halten und
sich daran zu orientieren und das habe
ich genauso eingehalten
nach der letzten nach dem letzten
bundesparteitag und ich gehe davon aus
dass das auch für 2020 gilt das wird
dann noch etwas anspruchsvoller weil die
nächsten bundestagswahlen vor uns haben
aber meine feste überzeugung ist dass
das erneut geht
aber noch die frage nach der tatsache ob
sie der kandidat von 20 18 sind oder ob
sie dazugelernt haben wir also ich hoffe
ihnen jetzt genauso wie mir und lernt
jeden tag dazu und ich habe ja jetzt
auch die chance gehabt in den letzten 15
monaten wieder etwas näher heranzurücken
auch an die politik hier in berlin
ich war 2018 weit weg und will trotzdem
bei 48 prozent angekommen ich bin jetzt
viel näher dran ich habe viel engere
kontakte auch wieder zu den
bundestagsabgeordneten
ich kenne sehr viel mehr jetzt auch von
denen die ich noch nicht kennengelernt
hatte in meiner aktiven zeit
ich stelle in der bundestagsfraktion
fest dass viele die mich 2018 nicht
gewählt haben weil sie gesagt haben wenn
er märz gewählt wird gibt es neuwahlen
und sie alle neuwahlen nicht wollten
jetzt sagen wenn der märz gewählt wird
haben wir die besten chancen unsere
wahlkreise zurückzugewinnen und insofern
ändert sich da auch mir gegenüber die
stimmung und ich freue mich über jeden
tag wo ich auch gerade jüngere kollegen
noch etwas intensiver kennen gelernt
habe so wie zum beispiel gestern abend
philipp amthor in mecklenburg vorpommern
das macht einfach großen spaß
die jüngeren abgeordneten dort zu sehen
wie sie auch in ihren wahlkreisen
arbeiten und natürlich lerne ich auch
dazu was man machen kann
die nächste frage der von uns aus
gesehen rechten seite bei harmlosen
haben sich sogar richtig verstanden
haben eben gesagt wenn er vorsitzender
wird dann ist das auch das cdu angebot
in der debatte mit der csu um
kanzlerkandidat gilt das für sie auch
wenn sie gewählt werden sind sie das cdu
angebot zum thema kanzlerkandidat ganz
gleich was dann mit der csu findet vom 2
ein stellvertreter platz würde ja wenn
er frei würde
anfang april vermutlich auch gleich
wieder gesetzt
mit herrn spahn wie sieht denn dann ihre
einbindung ihre ich nenne mal formale
einbildung die cdu-führung aus
spätestens im winter wird ja dann wieder
komplett gewählt also jeder cdu
parteivorsitzende ist grundsätzlich
geeignet bundeskanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland zu werden
es war immer so in der geschichte der
cdu und das bleibt hoffentlich auch so
trotzdem steht vor dieser entscheidung
die einigung mit der csu
und ich habe immer großen respekt vor
der csu in ihrer eigenständigkeit gehabt
wir müssen diesen gegenseitigen respekt
auch bewahren
ich war wie die meisten von ihnen wissen
im jahr 2002 für die kanzlerkandidatur
des damaligen parteivorsitzenden der csu
edmund stoiber das sind
ausnahmesituationen die gibt es in
großen abständen vielleicht aber wir
werden uns auch dieses mal mit der csu
darüber verständigen und in der
reihenfolge der entscheidungen wie sie
gerade beschrieben habe und daran werde
ich mich halten es geht eins nach dem
anderen
wenn ja wie gut ist ihr mit hat ja heute
seine entscheidung zusammen mit die
entspannt hier auch vorgetragen respekt
dafür das ist in ordnung dann steht der
bundesparteitag im dezember an dritter
bis fünfter zwölfter und dann steht die
gesamte neuwahl des parteipräsidiums an
und spätestens bis dahin werde ich mich
entscheiden
aber nochmal ich spiele hier nicht auf
platz sondern auf sieg und deswegen
beschäftige ich mich mit der frage auch
ernsthaft nicht ich will gewinnen
wir bleiben für die nächste frage am
gleichen micro die kollegin daneben
jede kollegin neben harmlosen sie haben
von einer krise in der cdu gesprochen
was ist ihr außenpolitischer blick ich
meine in europa die verfassung der sache
ist das beste praxis und aus also
weltweit china trampel so also was ist
eigentlich oder wie unterscheiden sie
sich von der von einem kurs von frau von
der frau merkel also ich lasse mich
jetzt nicht gegen die bundeskanzlerin ab
sondern ich sage ihnen meine persönliche
meinung und meine auffassung was wir tun
müssen wir sind mit wir sind mit 82
millionen einwohnern das
bevölkerungsreichste land der
europäischen union wir liegen in der
geostrategischen mitte dieses
europäischen kontinents deutschland hat
ob wir das nun wollen oder nicht eine
verantwortung die weit über die
verantwortung des eigenen landes hinaus
reicht wir haben eine europäische
verantwortung geheime eine globale
verantwortung die welt guckt auf
deutschland und insofern meine ich dass
wir sehr viel mehr engagement in der
außenpolitik zeigen müssten wir müssen
sehr viel mehr engagement auch in der
sicherheitspolitik der äußeren der
inneren sicherheit das geht ineinander
über auch europäisch koordinieren
ich hab das eben in meiner eingangs
bemerkung gesagt ich bedaure bis zum
heutigen tag das hier nicht bessere
antworten auf makro haben
ich finde dass die kritik in brüssel die
ich immer wieder höre wenn ich dort bin
dass deutschland zu wenig präsent ist zu
wenig engagiert ist zu wenig führt
durchaus berechtigt ist
deutschland muss bereit sein zu führen
in der europäischen union auch zusammen
mit anderen das wird von uns erwartet
das ist nicht etwas was wir uns was wir
auf drängen oder aufnötigen sondern das
ist eine erwartung die wie ich finde zu
recht an deutschland gestellt wird und
vielleicht lassen sie mich das mal auf
den einen nenner bringen wir werden eine
trikolore welt sehen im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert in amerika
wird sich herausnehmen aus dieser rolle
der globalen ordnungsmacht
china wird versuchen diese rolle zum
teil zu spielen und europa einer von
ihnen hat es mal geschrieben vor einigen
wochen antwortet mit routinierter
ratlosigkeit
das war der begriff den ich gelesen habe
und der mir eigentlich gut gefallen hat
nicht weil die beschreibung des
zustandes so wunderbar ist sondern weil
dieser begriff leider zutrifft
routinierte ratlosigkeit kann aber keine
antwort auf die globalen
herausforderungen sein vor denen wir
alle stehen
europa muss den anspruch stellen nicht
sag es mal mit dem wort von jean claude
juncker ist auch sehr gut gefallen hat
fast schon ein vermächtnis seiner zeit
der europa muss weltpolitik fähig werden
so und wenn europa weltpolitik fähig
werden will dann geht das nicht ohne
oder gar gegen deutschland dann geht das
nur mit deutschland und deutschland muss
dann wirklich vorne mit sitzen und auch
die richtung bestimmen und das erwarte
ich eigentlich von uns und das erwarte
ich auch von jeder zukünftigen regierung
ja wobei diese diskussion über den sitz
im un-sicherheitsrat also den ständigen
sitz habe ich immer für eine etwas
künstliche diskussion gehalten
ja das kann man machen aber das ist
nicht die entscheidende frage vor der
wir stehen wir müssen bevor wir uns mit
dem sicherheitsrat der vereinten
nationen beschäftigen mit der
europäischen außen- und
sicherheitspolitik beschäftigen und je
einiger wir uns sind und je besser wir
da auch zusammen stehen hier
glaubwürdiger wird auch das engagement
des in deutschland ist er zurzeit nicht
ständiges mitglied im un sicherheitsrat
die koordinierung die ich in new york
sehe zwischen den ständigen mitgliedern
den nicht-ständigen mitgliedern auf der
europäischen seite ist eine viel bessere
antwort als die ständige diskussion über
den sitz deutschlands den ständigen sitz
im un sicherheitsrat
die bessere koordinierung untereinander
lässt die unterschiede zwischen
ständigen und nicht ständigen
mitgliedern im un sicherheitsrat auch
etwas in den hintergrund treten
also wir müssen als europäer gemeinsam
und geschlossen auftrete und das gilt
auch für new york
der vor zu stuttgarter zeitung von einer
richtungsentscheidung gesprochen
inwiefern betrifft oder wo verorten sie
sich da es geht ja sehr viel darüber
gesprochen sondern eher die eine million
verlorene stimmen so afd oder die eine
million stimmen zu den grünen nachjagen
sie haben selbst immer schon gesagt wie
gern bestimmte art halbiert also ist es
so sagen die richtungsentscheidung dass
sie weniger in die mitte schauen worden
sondern starke an diese kernkompetenz
der union sage ich jetzt mal lager
rechts der mitte und der zweite
nachfrage noch zur europa politik
sie haben jetzt dafür gehalten mehr zu
tun
gleichzeitig haben sie vorhin gesagt
dass solange der eu außengrenze nicht
funktioniert deutschland sozusagen
selbst die territoriale integrität
herstellen muss heißt für mich jetzt die
grenzkontrollen permanent gibt es da
nicht ein widerspruch könnte sowas nicht
also das ist ja stellen damit schenken
denn fragen oder zumindest vorübergehend
nein also vielleicht mit der letzten
frage anfangen ich stelle schimmel nicht
in frage die dublin verordnung nicht in
frage so unzureichend sie vielleicht
auch sein mögen aber punktuelle und
anlassbezogene grenzkontrollen sind
zulässig
die haben übrigens auch schon im land
nordrhein-westfalen stattgefunden
kurz vor und während des g20-gipfels in
hamburg im sommer 2017 sind an den
nordrhein-westfälischen eu-grenzen
binnengrenzen kontrollen gemacht worden
also das ist nichts was jetzt
außergewöhnlich ist das können wir
machen das dürfen wir machen und nach
meinem gefühl müssen wir das auch machen
das erwartet die bevölkerung auch von
der politischen führung und ich möchte
nie wieder erleben oder hören dass hier
von einem kontrollverlust gesprochen
wird wenn eine regierung die kontrolle
über den zuzug in das eigene land
verliert dann darf sie sich nicht
darüber wundern dass sie das vertrauen
der menschen verliert was die
positionierung der cdu betrifft ich habe
das immer gesagt und bleibe bei meiner
meinung es geht hier nicht um eine
rechts verschiebung der union sondern es
geht darum das fundament wieder breiter
zu machen
dafür zu sorgen dass die liberalen und
konservativen wähler auch in der cdu
wieder eine heimat haben
wir haben uns zu sehr verengt und wir
müssen wieder breiter aufgestellt sein
das muss natürlich auch durch personen
sichtbar gemacht werden das ist leider
gegenwärtig nicht der fall
und da glaube ich liegt eine große
chance für uns ich würde das anders
sehen argumentativ auch dem folgen was
zum beispiel von armin laschet
vorgetragen wird das habe ich ihm auch
so gesagt wenn wir zur zeit bei sagen
wir mal 38 prozent legen und die grünen
bei 5 10 oder 12
dann würde ich akzeptieren dass wir da
mehr zu verlieren haben als an anderer
stelle zu gewinnen aber das ist nicht so
wir haben diese wählerinnen und wähler
bereits verloren
und deswegen müssen dass sie von beiden
seiten zurückgewinnen wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass die ganze umweltpolitik und
rate immer dazu auch parteimitglieder
die das kritisch sehen wir haben ein
massives problem
der klimawandel ist ein massives problem
aber wir müssen uns sehr wohl mit den
grünen darüber streiten wie wir dieses
problem lösen
und da habe ich ganz andere meinungen
als ein großteil der grünen
wir müssen diese wählerinnen und wähler
ansprechen deswegen habe ich in meinem
ersten punkt eben mit der jungen
generation begonnen wir müssen der
jungen generation in deutschland eine
zukunft geben wir müssen auch mit
industrie arbeitsplätzen in deutschland
eine zukunft geben und das müssen wir
verbinden miteinander ökologie und
ökonomie gute wirtschaft und gute
umweltpolitik das passt zusammen und das
können wir gleichzeitig müssen wir dafür
sorgen dass diejenigen die sich als
konservativ empfinden und dies
vielleicht auch sind auch in der cdu
wieder ihre heimat haben
ich habe ihn in erinnerung einen beitrag
eines meinungsforschers mit der
überschrift die afg als chance für die
union so und wenn sie diesen artikel
lesen dass einige zeit her
dann kommt darin ein teil der strategie
der parteiführung der cdu zum ausdruck
und diese strategie teile ich
ausdrücklich nicht die afd ist keine
chance für die union die afg ist eine
herausforderung eine provokation
und sie ist auch ein
ja hat politischer wettbewerber um die
wählerinnen und wähler die zum teil
früher bei uns war und die möchte ich
gerne zurück gewinnen frau aigner hat
die nächste frage in der mitte herr merz
man ihnen zuhört dann bringt er ja doch
eine sehr deutliche eile durch
gleichzeitig über ich eine eilig haben
mit einer neuausrichtung und sie reden
von der staatspolitischen verantwortung
dass sie keine neuwahlen anstreben
wollen aber da stellt sich mir die frage
was wird in ihre forderung an die
bundeskanzlerin sein und auch an die
gruppe an den koalitionspartner diese
punkte in ihrem sinne bereits neu
auszurichten oder voranzutreiben weil
wenn sie sprechen von einer verengung
die stattgefunden hat die wäre ja dann
die verengung der ära merkel da werden
sie sich doch nicht anderthalb jahre
noch zeit lassen dass das so bleibt also
eile
dafür gibt es grund genug wir können
nicht lange warten mit den zuständen die
wir hier in diesem lande sehen und da
ist thüringen ja nur ein beispiel das
ist nun ein sonder beispiel das wird
sich auch an anderer stelle
wahrscheinlich nicht wiederholen aber
wir haben im nächsten jahr
landtagswahlen unter anderem in
sachsen-anhalt auch unter sehr
schwierigen vorzeichen da muss klarheit
auf der datei ebene bestehen das hat mit
der bundesregierung zunächst einmal nur
am rande etwas zu tun die partei muss
sich hier in diesen fragen klar
positionieren und sie muss wissen wie
sie mit diesen themen umgeht und dann
werden wir selbstverständlich auch
darüber sprechen aber wissen die
gedanklich stehen für mich die partei
und die regierung auf zwei verschiedenen
ebenen
die partei muss wieder eigenständiger
denken und handeln und muss sich lösen
auch von von diesen letzten jahren um in
die zukunft zu schauen und zu sagen was
machen wir eigentlich in zukunft besser
und das kann man bei den landtagswahlen
schon beginnen also ich nehme das
beispiel sachsen anhalt das wird eine
schwierige landtagswahl werden wir haben
in rheinland-pfalz und in
baden-württemberg
landtagswahlen in baden württemberg
landtagswahlen wo die grünen vorne
sitzen und wir im beifahrersitz
wie gehen wir mit einer solchen
situation um in einem land in dem wir
mal über jahrzehnte die stärkste partei
gewesen sind so das heißt wir müssen in
beide richtungen arbeiten und das hat
mit der arbeit der bundesregierung die
dann ja auch langsam ausläuft
allenfalls am rande etwas zu tun und
wenn ich ratschläge zu geben aber oder
wenig diskussionen zu führen habe gerade
mit der bundeskanzlerin da werde ich das
mit ihr tun unter vier augen und nicht
in der bundespressekonferenz kurze
nachfrage aber wenn es darum geht welche
führungsrolle deutschland haben soll
dann hat es sehr wohl durch das
regierung zu tun und was wird denn da
ihre anforderungen an die jetzige
bundeskanzlerin seien würden sie mir
zugestehen dass ich das erst mit ihr
besprechen
nach meiner wahl und dann ihnen dazu
etwas sagen weil ich finde das wäre die
richtige reihenfolge man muss ja wissen
wofür sie dann stehen aber das habe ich
gerade nun klar und deutlich gesagt die
nächste frage hat der kollege ungefähr
drei reihen dahinter genau martina
anderes hat herr merz zwei fragen sie
haben gesagt sie spielen auf sieg nicht
auf platz schließt das auch aus dass sie
im falle einer regierungsumbildung in
der laufenden wahlperiode in die
regierung eintreten und im falle eines
wahlsieges von herrn asche 20 21 einer
regierung auch nicht angehören werden
und die zweite frage sie haben gesagt
sie steht auch für ein feiner starke
europapolitik mehr europa nicht weniger
in der vergangenheit haben sie sich
relativ hart zum beispiel griechenland
geäußert die hätten sie am liebsten
nicht außerhalb der eurozone gesehen
könnte da etwas konkreter noch werden
wie sie ihre grundlegende
europapolitischen vorstellungen sind
gerade mit bezug auf vertiefung der
eurozone
ja also zunächst einmal ich beantworte
keine was wäre wenn fragen sondern jetzt
geht es um die frage des
parteivorsitzenden
armin laschet hat eine entscheidung
getroffen für den stellvertretenden
parteivorsitzenden und damit ist das
jetzt klar für den bundesparteitag am 25
april was die europa politik und
insbesondere die euro politik betrifft
habe ich nie ein geheimnis daraus
gemacht dass ich die politik der
europäischen zentralbank für
kritikwürdig ansehe
bei allem respekt vor ihrer
unabhängigkeit aber
die wiederaufnahme des ankaufprogramms
im letzten jahr die hat aus meiner sicht
zu recht
auch innerhalb der europäischen
zentralbank ziemlich heftige kritik
ausgelöst ich teile diese kritik ich
sehe nicht dass das wirklich notwendig
gewesen wäre und ich habe ihm wenn ich
mich recht erinnere im mai 2015 bin ich
ganz sicher ob das datum stimmt aber im
mai 2015 die entscheidung der
europäischen finanzminister griechenland
nicht länger zu finanzieren es gab einen
einstimmigen beschluss der europäischen
finanzminister damals wolfgang schäuble
noch der deutsche finanzminister für
richtig gehalten
das haben die staats und regierungschefs
dann passiert aber ich habe diese
entscheidung damals für richtig gehalten
gut aber das anders entschieden worden
respektiert aber ich würde mich im
wiederholungsfalle er auf der seite der
finanzminister sehen als auf der seite
der staats- und regierungschefs
wir haben noch eine knappe viertelstunde
zeit ich habe noch wahnsinnig viele
frage auf der liste kann nicht
versprechen dass noch alle ran kommen
deswegen der appell kurze fragen kurze
antworten die minister hatten ja nachts
nachfrage zu ihrer äußerung zum
grenzkontrollen seien es eben mit dem
verweis begründet auch die kontrollen in
nordrhein-westfalen im zusammenhang mit
dem g20 gipfel in hamburg das waren
temporäre grenzkontrollen nach dem
schengen regime ähnlich wie vor dem g7
gipfel in ellmau auf welcher
rechtsgrundlage
glauben sie dass man solche
grenzkontrollen als migrations
politisches instrument verstetigen kann
und eine zweite nachfrage auch in den
juristen sie haben eben mit blick auf
das team
laschet sparen von einer kartellbildung
zur schwäche und das recht des
wettbewerbs gesprochen korrigieren sie
mich wenn ich das falsch verstanden habe
aus dem munde eines wirtschaftsjuristen
kann man auch daraus ablesen dass sie
das möglicherweise für mindestens unfair
wenn ich illegitim halten
ich hab das ja gesagt im richtigen leben
hätte man das so bezeichnet ich habe das
ja in anführungsstrichen gesetzt im
richtigen leben oder im wirtschaftsleben
von mir aus ist richtiges leben gut also
an verstanden ich hab es ironisch
gemeint habe ich habe auch gelernt in
der politik hat ironie kein platz also
jetzt sage es noch mal richtig im
wirtschaftsleben hätte man es eine kann
bildung zu lasten des wettbewerbs
genannt in der politik ist es
selbstverständlich legitim und in
ordnung weil ich die kontrolle an den
grenzen ist in der tat nur punktuell und
anlassbezogen zulässig der streit geht
bis heute ob 2015 2016 ein solcher
anlass da gewesen wäre
die partei hat unter der führung von
annegret kramp karrenbauer genau im
letzten jahr um diese zeit mit diesem
werkstattgespräch genau das auch so
gesehen sie hat gesagt als ultima ratio
müssen grenzkontrollen auch möglich sein
und wir dürfen nie wieder vom
kontrollverlust sprechen müssen so diese
position theilig und die ist schengen
konform dies dublin konform die ist
rechtlich ohne weiteres und ohne
einschränkung zulässig aber auf
politischen hintergründen blickwinkel zu
sprechen sie haben für mehr europa und
nicht weniger kompliziert und
gleichzeitig sprechen sie von
grenzkontrollen er ist es was
unterscheidet sie von viktor orban und
zweitens was ist das spiel ein signal
gerade solidarisch ist es nicht so
länder wie griechenland oder italien
oder spanien die an der front diese
flüchtlingswelle stellen
also vielen dank für die frage gibt mir
gelegenheit das nochmal klarzustellen
ich beobachte schon seit geraumer zeit
die diskussion auch über die
flüchtlingslager oder die starke
belastung ihres landes mit flüchtlingen
und ich habe noch in erinnerung die
diskussion über lampedusa
als die ersten großen flüchtlingswellen
in lampedusa ankamen haben wir hier in
deutschland und viele in deutschland
gesagt ist ein problem italiens und
jetzt neigen viele dazu zu sagen lesbos
ist ein problem von griechenland da bin
ich ganz anderer meinung
was im lampedusa geschehen ist und was
dann anschließend folgen hatte für alle
ist genauso wie das was jetzt in ihrem
land auf einigen inseln passiert kein
individuelles problem von italien und
jetzt von griechenland sondern ein
europäisches problem von uns allen
und da gibt es meines erachtens eine
sehr große verantwortung die sogar über
die grenzen der europäischen union
hinaus reicht was spricht eigentlich
dagegen dass wir uns sehr viel stärker
engagieren in der finanzierung der
flüchtlingslager die in der türkei und
in syrien errichtet werden die
menschenunwürdige unterbringung dieser
menschen millionen dort ist doch kein
problem von der türkei oder von syrien
sondern ist auch ein humanitäres problem
für uns alle
also von daher bin ich dezidiert der
meinung dass wir da sehr viel mehr tun
müssen und vielleicht ist es sogar
ökonomisch richtig viel früher zu helfen
als erst zu warten bis die menschen dann
hier sind und wir hier größte
integrationsprobleme unterbringungs
probleme und alle probleme haben die
dazu gehören also ich plädiere sehr
dafür gerade hier mehr verantwortung zu
übernehmen auch wenn diese probleme
zurzeit vielleicht nur regional oder
lokal begrenzt sind das ist für mich
europa solidarität auch in solchen
schwierigen frage herr feldenkirchen mit
der nächsten frage herr merz vor knapp
16 monaten saßen sie am selben ort um
ihre kandidatur um den parteivorsitz
anzukündigen
sie hatten damals zwei ernstzunehmende
konkurrenten letztlich heute haben sie
wieder einen ernstzunehmenden
konkurrenten und eine ernst zu nehmende
kartellbildung was würden sie im
rückblick sagen
20.18 was waren die hauptgründe dafür
dass sie ist wenn auch sehr knapp
damals nicht vorsitzender geworden sind
und was sagt ihnen ihr politischer ins
beziehungsweise ihre lager analyse waren
die chancen für sie vorsitzender zu
werden damals besser oder jetzt also
wenn ich mich richtig erinnere sich
heute ein platz weiter links als 2018
aber ich habe 2018 aus dem stand heraus
innerhalb von fünf wochen 48 prozent auf
dem parteitag erreicht das sind ist für
sich genommen schon mal ein großer
erfolg gewesen auch wenn wir die letzten
16 stimmen gefehlt haben und ich sag das
hier ganz offen wenn ich an dem tag eine
bessere rede gehalten hätte hätte ich
wahrscheinlich die mehrheit gehabt auf
dem portal der mann ist nicht jeden tag
gleich gut in form wie ich auch nicht so
und dieses mal ist die lage anders
ich bin sehr viel näher dran
ich habe in den letzten 15 monaten das
habe ich eben schon gesagt sehr viele
mitglieder der partei funktionsträger
mandatsträger näher kennengelernt ich
bin in der partei sehr viel
herumgekommen und aus meiner sicht sind
die chancen in diesem jahr sehr viel
besser als im jahr 2008 sind für die
nächste frage geben die auf die von uns
aus gesehen linke seite letzte reihe die
kollegin
[Musik]
sie haben eben gesagt die passieren
dürfen
man hat ja durchaus versucht auch von
der bundespolitik da einfluss zu nehmen
offensichtlich ist es nicht gelungen hat
man da den draht zu den ostverbänden
verloren und wir wollen diese sie die
wieder besser einbinden
also ich gebe mal eine etwas
ausführlichere antwort das erste ist ich
hätte mich wohler gefühlt wenn die
bundes partei das thema abgrenzung nach
links und abgrenzung nach rechts macht
jetzt mal etwas vereinfacht nicht in
einem beschluss sondern in zwei
beschlüssen formuliert hätte das hätte
nämlich zu einer größeren
differenzierung die möglichkeit gegeben
so war das alles in einem beschluss in
einem papier in einem satz ich finde die
differenzierung ist notwendig wir haben
zurzeit in deutschland mit
linksradikalismus probleme aber die sind
weitgehend unter kontrolle
wir haben mit rechtsradikalismus massive
probleme und die sind nicht unter
kontrolle
und deswegen müssen auch aus diesem
grund aber auch aus historischen gründen
die abgrenzungen unterschiedlich
ausfallen das thema mit der afg auch den
einzelnen leuten die dort in dieser
partei aktiv sind hat eine zutiefst
historische dimension
für uns als christdemokraten ohnehin
aber für das ganze land
die letztendlich auch mit den dunkelsten
geschichte teil der geschichte unseres
landes zusammenhängt und das muss man
anders formulieren das muss man anders
zum ausdruck bringen als eine abgrenzung
nach links trotzdem bleibe ich dabei es
kann für die cdu keine zusammenarbeit
mit der linkspartei geben auch wenn ein
ministerpräsident wie herr ramelow ich
kenne ihn persönlich nicht er soll ja
ganz nett und freundlich sein aber herr
ramelow ist bewusst mitglied dieser
partei geworden er ist ja nicht gezogen
worden als mitglied dieser partei als
aus dem westen gekommen ist mitglied in
dieser partei geworden
vertritt eine partei die in ihrem
grundsatzprogramm große teile
unserer gesellschaftsordnung
rechtsordnung verfassungsordnung
wirtschaftsordnung in frage stellt eine
partei die bis hin zu dieser gruppe
marx21 trotzkisten in ihren reihen hat
und das ist eine linie von herrn ramelow
bismarcks 21 das ist diese partei
sondern mit dieser partei kann es für
christdemokraten egal wo in thüringen in
sachsen anhalt in deutschland keine
zusammenarbeit geben und ich hätte mir
deswegen gewünscht dass wir sehr viel
früher habe es versucht aber mehr auch
nicht gelungen ich hatte auch die
autorität dafür nicht weil ich eben kein
parteivorsitzender war und bin sehr viel
früher auch mit den landtags kollegen
landtagsabgeordneten kandidaten sprechen
müssen was macht die im falle von iks
und das war ja absehbar die umfragen
haben ja gezeigt dass eine solche
situation eintreten könnte dass die afg
und die linkspartei zusammen mehr als 50
prozent der sitze im typischen alltag
bekommen das war absehbar und die
verfassung in thüringen ist auch
jedermann zugänglich und man kann darin
lesen wie wahlen von ministerpräsidenten
stattzufinden haben so und das muss
jetzt eine eine eine gelernte lektion
sein
beim nächsten mal muss das besser werden
und ich werde morgen abend den apolda
auf einem aschermittwoch auf einer
aschermittwochsveranstaltung den
freunden aus thüringen auch sagen ihr
habt da einen riesengroßen fehler
gemacht und meine feste meinung ist dass
dieser dafür werdet ihr den kopf
hinhalten müssen und ich bin für frühe
neuwahlen
und dann wird es ein sehr schlechtes
ergebnis geben für die cdu aber das ist
im april nächsten jahres nicht anders
als im sommer 2020
und wenn wir dann den neuwahlen geben
dann versprechen wir euch dann geht die
gesamte führung der cdu mit euch
zusammen in diese neuwahl und wir
kämpfen für eine bessere zeit und für
eine bessere position so dass es meine
haltung im umgang auch mit solchen
sachverhalten
höhere sensibilität auch im hinblick auf
den osten
ja also ich glaube es gibt wenige in der
cdu die in den letzten anderthalb zwei
jahren so viel in ostdeutschland
unterwegs gewesen sind wie ich es war
also wir haben mal nachgezählt ich bin
in den letzten anderthalb jahren über 30
mal zu veranstaltungen in aus
deutschland gewesen
und ich glaube ich ich wollte da auch
hin weil ich es auch besser verstehen
wollte weil ich mehr reden wollte und
mehr zu hören wollte und ja aus
deutschland ist anders sie haben eine
andere geschichte sie haben eine andere
demokratie erfahrung die ich sehr viel
kürzer sie haben andere erfahrungen mit
autoritären politischen systemen mit
zwei systemen
man muss respektieren dass dieser teil
unseres landes in großen politischen
fragen auch gesellschaftspolitischen
fragen anders denkt und darauf muss man
sich einlassen
vielleicht schaffen wir noch zwei fragen
geste hat herr herholz im märz wenn ich
sie richtig verstanden haben sie gesagt
dass man sachverhalte wie in thüringen
die in zukunft von der partei
beantworten müsse wie kann man sich das
in der praxis vorstellen dass die
bundeskanzlerin dann bei dem nächsten
parteivorsitz ist dann erst einmal ihre
statements vorher vorliegen und sie
haben erklärt dass nach dem parteitag
ich nehme an sie machen den
sonderparteitag 7 mit herrn söder falls
sie gewählt werden sollten über eine
kabinettsumbildung reden würden um dann
mit der bundeskanzlerin darüber halte
sie für sinnvoll dass ein parteivorsitz
der cdu so wie es frau kramp karrenbauer
gemacht hat auch mitglied des kabinetts
sein weil das sind jetzt drei fragen die
die erste frage will ich mal mit einem
klaren nein beantworten die erste frage
das ist eine angelegenheit der partei
und erst in dem augenblick wo so aus dem
ruder läuft wie es aus dem ruder
gelaufen ist kann man verstehen dass
sich die bundeskanzlerin dazu geäußert
hat aber ich hätte mir gewünscht dass
das gar nicht erst nötig wird
und dann müssen wir auch eine strikte
trennung zwischen partei und
regierungsverantwortung in solchen
fragen wahrnehmen
die bundeskanzlerin ein
kabinettsmitglied kann sich um solche
regionale sachverhalte nicht kümmern
dafür ist eine partei das haben wir in
früheren jahren geschafft und das müssen
wir wieder schaffen wir müssen darauf
achten dass solche sachverhalte und
solche situationen wie die in thüringen
schon im vorfeld erkannt werden und dass
man damit so umgeht dass solche
abstimmungen wie dann mit der wahl von
herrn kemmerich das gar nicht entstehen
und das ist für mich führung frühzeitig
erkennen oder möglicherweise probleme
entstehen und sie erst gar nicht zum
ausbruch kommen zu lassen
dann schaffen wir noch einen letzten
märz dann gehen wir mit der frage zu den
kollegen nebenfrauen mayer-wegelin frau
meier davon kurz meinen sie hatten in
ihren einleitenden worten herr merz
gesagt dass wir ein massives problem mit
rechtsradikalismus habe das land bislang
unterschätzt haben dann so haben sie
aber sehr schnell über rechtsfreie räume
in innenstädten und grenzkontrollen
gesprochen schließlich daraus richtig
dass ihre antwort auf das problem des
rechtsradikalismus die stärkere
thematisierung von kleinkriminalität
grenzkontrollen und reiter ist und wenn
nicht was wäre sie dann die antwort ist
ja
kurze antwort die letzte antwort für
heute viele fragen sind offen leben
bleibt so dass sie wiederkommen vielen
dank heute fehlen
ja und das war friedrich merz meine
damen und herren wie unterschiedlich
doch auftritte sein können die spiele
auf sieg und nicht